now are you on twitter if you're not  don't worry  we've got you covered gareth southgate  has just posted a video  and the boss has a message for you  um just wanted to take the time to say  thank you to everybody for  the incredible support we've received  throughout this tournament  we hope that we've represented you in  the right way  we hope that you've enjoyed watching us  play  i'm very grateful to all of the players  and the incredible staff i've got with  me  that we've been able to get to our first  final for 55 years  but of course we know now we've got to  deliver for you so  we'll be doing everything we can your  support  and energy has given us a huge lift and  i know it will  on sunday